walk him to this video playing GM
Grandmaster rickets rickets from from
France maxime lagati I'm a plate in the
number of times I'm playing a very
modest opening here the London system
okay well nevertheless it's it's losing
a 10-point owaisi 65 but still I want I
want the pawn on c5 to get the active
night development going yeah I should be
about equal this position nothing
special happening
yeah what I would tell what I laughs
what I try to do is not to form much
behind on the clock who try to play in
sorry I've tried to play quickly
exchanged some pieces sort of asking him
okay what are you going to do him
that's that's very exciting very
exciting chess well okay what can you do
with a guy played the London and
basically did nothing
yes I've got to cut the deform so I'm
probably not much to write home about
but still I don't know 5v5 f5 can I get
some activity going here maybe h5 gains
some space King to have 6 h-4 so I
played this really a bit strange Joe
well he cannot go to cannot play rugae
for anyway checkmate oh man what the
game ok ok Oh funny yeah okay what can I
say we just we just rated of pieces it
was a bit it was a bit weird before I if
I you can play of course but I still it
was a bit unnecessary maybe rookie one
here I cannot really keep keep you for
anyway but after this i have a slide pol
definitely with with the d file yeah
this is this is good for black clearly I
have some ideas I can push me five maybe
f6 g5 gaining space until it's not so
it's so easy yeah okay for us of course
funny it's kind of a self meet the only
yeah okay rook a2 a3 are the same but
it's really meeting yourself quite quite
funny yeah maybe yet too much good
French wine or anything but funny and
nevertheless free thanks for watching